oh my God it's good Brendan Frazier in a
fat suit there's no [__] way at some
point I'm not gonna start laughing I
just was trying to guess where the movie
was going and you know because he wants
to help his daughter I was picturing
she'd have like an abusive boyfriend
which doesn't happen and he's too big to
stop it so at one point you know he
lives on the second floor is apartment
building that like they were fighting
underneath the balcony now this picture
I'm like ah
getting up out of the thing and then
just [__] walking over the balcony
Paul and just going like this not even
just just leaning forward
and just flipping over like a bowling
pit
and Landing straight down and crushing
the other dude I laugh like [__] five
minutes so my wife was holding my arm I
was trying to laugh quietly and I was
[__] sitting there shaking
and she [__] just shook her head and
she let go of my arm
it was his [__]